In Switzerland, US National Security Advisor John Bolton...
...says he warned his Russian counterpart...
...not to interfere in the US midterm elections in November.
In France, a man with severe psychiatric problems...
...killed his mother and sister and seriously injured another woman...
...in a knife attack.
The Islamic State claims responsibility for the attack.
In South Africa, the country accuses US President Donald Trump...
...of stoking racial division in response to his tweet,...
...suggesting white farmers were having their lands taken from them and killed.
In Uganda, opposition Ugandan lawmaker Bobi Wine...
...was charged with treason on Thursday....
...over his alleged role in the stoning of President Yoweri Museveni's convoy last month.
Finally from Spain, Spanish authorities sent back 116 migrants from Morocco...
...who stormed the border fence at its Ceuta enclave in North Africa the day before.